mein name ist luca herzlich willkommen
wir heute meine lieben freunde zu einem
neuen video auf meinem kanal ich habe ja
schon zweimal auf amazon fans reagiert
und heute reagieren wir zum dritten mal
nicht richtig auf amazon fällt aber auf
jeden fall auf online-shopping fällig
schauen uns heute also ganz einfach
sachen an die leute online gesehen haben
und sich dachte nie dass sie cool aus
und das was sie bestellt haben sieht
dann allerdings komplett anders aus also
sie wurden enttäuscht und ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt an mit dem
ersten produkt und zwar ist es dieser
graue rudi auf dem geschrieben steht
statt petting racism ist patriot ist
also auf deutsch übersetzt auf die
einzubilden dass der rassismus
patriotismus es also einfach dass die
personen die diesen rudi trägt sagen wir
du bist ein bisschen zu weit gegangen
mit seinem patriotismus das geht schon
in die richtung rassismus ist eine gute
aussage ist eine richtige aussage
angekommen ist allerdings dieses produkt
und ja man liest quasi nur rassisten
gute aktion somit direkt ins negative
gegangen das war es wirklich kommt
freuen wir machen allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt uns was
dieser kuschelige oversize rotes wetter
angekommen ist allerdings dieser hier
[Applaus]
das hier ist das nächste kleidungsstück
dass wir uns heute anschauen werden uns
was ist ein t shirt mit einem großen
print darauf angekommen ist allerdings
dieser bringt gerade erst mit humor
nehmen machen wir allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem nächsten online shopping
fell und zwar geht es dabei um dieses
kleid sieht eigentlich schön aus ist ein
schönes normal langes kleid für eine
frau angekommen ist allerdings dass
[Musik]
lauda ich das weil neben nadal denn wenn
ich das als frau bestellt hat und bei
mir zu hause wird einfach so ein
richtiges holzfäller herrenhemd ankommen
würde ich mir auch so der gay zeigt ihr
dorf alter und apropos durch meine damen
und herren auch mein gott das war die
beschlüsse über leitung aller zeiten
soeben ist ebenfalls eine neue folge des
podcast von sandra und mir online
gegangen und zwar von dem dick und doof
podcast ihr findet unten in der video
beschreibung einen link da könnt ihr
drauf klicken und dann könnt ihr euch
den podcast anhören auf spotify apple
podcast dieser keine ahnung wo also mich
würd's sehr freuen wenn er einfach mal
unten nachdem wie die beschreibung
schaut euch den podcast anhört dann noch
nicht reden über
30 nicht mehr wir haben nie ein thema
wir lachen eigentlich die ganze zeit und
darüber was für peinliche sachen wir
wochenende gemacht haben also checkt
gerne wahr die wie du schreibst aber
jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten online
shopping fällen und zwar ist es dieses
mega große plüschige kissen in form und
dem aussehen eines pandas angekommen ist
allerdings dieses kissen nicht mal so
groß wie eine haben allerdings direkt
zum nächsten online shopping fans war es
diesmal kein kleidungsstück oder ein
kissen sondern ein stuhl beziehungsweise
irgendwann sitz mit einem hebel vorne
dran also vielleicht könnte es auch
irgendwie so ein sitz sein für ein auto
spiel
ich weiß es nicht angekommen ist auf
jeden fall diese größe also ja viel spaß
beim draufsetzen
und der nächste online shopping fei
leider muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen das
tut mir richtig leid weil darunter
standen text und das war von einem
kleinen mädchen
ich meine ich zeige es euch erst mal und
zwar geht es um diesen teddybären und
das ist ein kleiner süßer teddybär und
ein mädchen hat sich den gewünscht zu
weihnachten und hat sich dann gedacht im
sommer jetzt ist es zu warm für den
twitter hat den bären dann den zwar
ausgezogen
[Musik]
ein mädel
ich kann mir das richtig vorstellt nicht
so richtig traurig und allerdings direkt
wieder zum nächsten online shopping
felder und zwar auch zu einer neuen
kategorie diesmal also nicht richtig
kategorie aber wir hatten noch nie so
eine art von produkt hier bei den
amazonen beziehungsweise online shopping
fans und zwar es ist ein flaschenkühler
und der sieht mega cool aus cool weil er
halt kühlt das hier ist auf jeden fall
das produkt das online zur schau
gestellt wurde bzw das produkt anzeige
bild und angekommen ist allerdings
leider diese größe der ganze vielleicht
ein schott glas drin
nun allerdings wieder zurück in die
kleidung spart und schauen uns dieses
ding an
ich weiß nicht was das ist ist das ein
jumpsuit ist das
clyde rose top mischungen ich weiß es
nicht genau auf jeden fall wurde so
damit geworden und es sieht aus als wird
das jetzt irgendwie eine normale person
da irgendwie tragen angekommen ist
allerdings dass hier ja ich meine sieht
genauso aus wie beschrieben wurde war
allerdings direkt bei der kleidung meine
lieben freunde und kommen nun zu dem
feld wo ich wirklich denke dass es mit
einer der witzigsten dieser episode
bisher und zwar ist das hier das
werbebild es geht nicht irgendwie um die
handschuhe oder schuhe oder ein t shirt
oder die hose sondern es geht um dieses
mal die sind umhänge schal westen
ähnliches ding sieht cool aus muss man
fragen können
angekommen ist allerdings dass hier
[Musik]
halloween kostüm
ich meine was denken sich denn
unternehmen dabei du hast mittlerweile
nahezu überall die möglichkeit so etwas
zurück zu schicken und mir kann kein
mensch sagen dass er das hier zu hause
behalten hätte und nicht zurück
geschickt hätte das hier ist das nächste
produkt um das es jetzt geht und zwar
sind es so snowboard ski schwer
beziehungsweise auch eventuell ganz
normale wanderschuhe für hoch schnee und
so weiter und so fort also wir sehen
auch die sind wirklich gut hier mit den
zu ziehen am rand und auch hier also mit
denen mit den schonern vorne dran das
macht auch wirklich sinn angekommen sind
einfach gummistiefel mit mit dem print
von von da habt ihr auch wieder den
vogel abgeschossen machen wir nun
allerdings weiter mit einer russland
flagge die sich jemand bestellen wollte
das hier ist ein screenshot von seiner
amazon bestellungen und als das
geliefert wurde dachte er sich schon ein
kleines paket kam da an
das lag einfach daran weil das hier
ankam ein schweißband also er hat eine
russland flagge bestellt für seinen
garten fünf fahnenmast und an kam ein
schweißband mit der pride flagge oder
lgbt kyu ich weiß es nicht genau was das
für eine flagge ist aber es ist auf
jeden fall keine russland flagge waren
wir nun weiter mit einem hygieneprodukte
und zwar einer facebook also einer
gesichtsmaske von wegen feuchtigkeit in
der fr
und so weiter und so fort und zwar hat
diese gesichtsmaske ebenfalls das design
von winnie puuh und ich meine es süß aus
jeder marc gini putzen süßer kleiner
pummeliger pr
als die person die maske sich auf
gesetzt hat sei es allerdings so aus als
ob ich denn verarscht ich allerdings
meine damen und herren was wäre eine
amazon- beziehungsweise der online
shopping fans folge von luca ohne eine
tasse und das hier ist die tasse es ist
eine glühbirne und wenn man heißt das
wasser rein filtern leuchtet sie ihr
wisst schon worauf es hinausläuft das
design ist einfach auf die tasse drauf
gedrückt worden
ein gewaltiger und beim nächsten produkt
hat sich wohl jemand auf einer
asiatischen website eine apple watch
bestellen wollen angekommen ist
allerdings eine iphone watch und wenn
wir mal raus zoomen sie schon das ist
einfach ja bis smart watch komplettem
apple-design allerdings nicht von apple
sondern aus irgendeiner fake asiatischen
firma also auch da wirklich props an
eure produktionsleistung und das hier
bildet das nächste produkt bei unseren
online shopping fällt es ist ein schöner
weißer flauschiger vorlege teppich fürs
bett wo man dann irgendwie einen schal
drauf schmeißen kann der bettdecke oder
irgendwelche hausschuhe angekommen ist
allerdings dass hier und nun ja das ist
jetzt nicht so groß ja das ist ärgerlich
was allerdings noch ärgerlicher ist es
wenn man sich wirklich ein produkt
bestellten das produkt kommt auch so an
die man denkt dass es irgendwie so wäre
also wie man es sich vorgestellt hat
doch dann entdeckt man plötzlich einen
rechtschreibfehler beziehungen
grammatikfehler und ich meine ihr könnt
ja mal kurz gucken und könnt gerne in
die kommentare schreiben was sie denkt
was sie falsch geschrieben ist oder was
falsch formuliert ist oder ob der satz
eurer meinung nach vielleicht doch sinn
ergibt aber schreibt mir das mal gern
und in die kommentare
allerdings würde ich jetzt nur noch
sagen dass wir zum letzten
online-shopping feld kommen für diese
folge uns was ist eine person die sich
ein zelt bestellen wollte als eine
person die wirklich zelten gehen wollte
am wochenende mit seinen kumpels und er
hat sich die größenangaben das zelt das
nicht angeguckt also die abmessungen und
das zelt kamen dann ein bisschen zu
klein war
wer hat das bessere team trotzdem rein
gesetzt also man sieht wirklich die
begeisterung in seinen augen geschrieben
anders hätte mich dass heute wieder ist
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese heutige episode
amazon beziehungsweise online shopping
fans gefallen hat wird ich mich selbst
dass wir dabei einen daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video hier freundschaften
wir 50.000 like es wird mir auf jeden
fall zeigen wir fanden es geil
wir wollten vierten teil dieser serie
also 50.000 likes wird mir auf jeden
fall zeigen hey ihr habt da mega bock
drauf hatte zudem noch kein abonnent von
meinem kanal seit warum leute es ist
kostenlos ihr könnt unter dem video
einfach auf diesen knopf drücken
abonnieren
dann verpasste keine videos mehr ich
sehen wir dass so viele leute also
wirklich 40 die sich meine videos
anschauen kein abonnent von meinem kanal
sind und leute ist es kostenlos also
dadurch verpasste keine videos mehr
und ja
ich hoffe euch geht's gut ich bin
erkältet aber sonst geht es mir
eigentlich ganz gut danke der nachfrage
[Musik]